value it's about value right it's you're  either entertaining people right you're  either creating a utility I mean why  didn't Instagram really work it wasn't a  social network it made us better at  taking photos which we care about and  that utility made it extremely popular  and then all the other layers came in so  you can either be a utility you could be  escapism because all of our lives are  busy and intense and we need a little  bit of escapism or you could be  entertainment and if you don't  understand that just look at the front  of your phone I promise you the things  that are on the front of your phone sit  in one of those three categories and the  front of your phone what is on your home  screen on your phone is the single  clearest gateway into the psychology of  what human beings care about in today's  society Wow oh yeah I could be smart too  I don't I I can be entertaining and  curse but I've got some thoughts